[Music]
if you imagine a typical American city
street and you take away the space
that's dedicated to cars you aren't left
with very much there's some narrow
walkways on the side and some bridges in
between them but not much else
cars dominate cities spend some time
walking around most cities and you'll
find yourself pushed to narrow sidewalks
waiting for crosswalk lights you'll find
cyclists navigating really narrow strips
of space Americans are used to cars the
way that fish are used to water and
that's so ubiquitous in the u.s. that I
think most people it just never occurs
to them that it could be otherwise but
what if there a way to change that to
give space back to pedestrians and
bicyclists and to make cities more
friendly to life outside of a car it
turns out Barcelona might have a
solution in 2014 the city was faced with
serious air pollution problems Barcelona
and its thirty five surrounding
municipalities consistently failed to
meet that you use air quality targets
and studies were showing that air
pollution in the region was causing
3,500 premature deaths every year
traffic in the city also causes severe
noise pollution so the city developed an
extensive urban mobility plan with the
hope of reducing traffic by 21 percent
the coolest part of the plan were these
things
they call them super Dias super Ria's
see super Dias
that translates to super blocks it's
this urban design concept intended to
minimize the presence of cars and city
centers the word super block has been
used before to describe huge city blocks
without any passageways for cars but
that's not what's happening here so
here's how Barcelona's plan works you
take nine squares city blocks and you
close off the inside to through traffic
so buses and big freight trucks or any
vehicles that are trying to get from one
part of town to the next
have to drive around the perimeter
inside the super block the speed limit
is kept to ten kilometers per hour that
translates to just over six miles per
hour and curbside parking is replaced by
underground parking and that means you
wind up with Street space for markets
and outdoor games and events within this
nine square block perimeter you're going
to have kind of a pleasant streetscape
where people can walk around and mingle
and do things without this kind of
constant fear of cars around the concept
is going to be tested out in five
neighborhoods but the city has
identified 120 possible intersections
throughout the region where it could be
implemented so how do we know what the
results of this kind of plan would look
like
well northwest of Barcelona is a city
called vitoria-gasteiz which has
implemented super block designs since
2008 in the main super block at the city
center pedestrian space increased from
45% of the total surface area to 74
percent and with so much less traffic
noise levels dropped from sixty six
point five decibels to sixty one
decibels most impressive of all there
was a 42% reduction in nitrogen oxide
emissions and a 38 percent reduction in
particle pollution in the area and on
top of that business is up what you
consistently see when people change
their Street scapes to prioritize human
beings over cars is you don't see any
decline in economic activity you see the
opposite you get more people walking and
cycling around more slowly stopping more
often patronizing businesses more and
that kind of sorted that social that
center of social activity will tend to
build on itself so here's the question
could something like this work in an
American city Barcelona has some unique
advantages getting started on this plan
in that a lot of it was built
before cars and a lot of it was built on
a simple grid the district of a shampo
which is where the superblock plan is
based was designed in 1859 in this
repetitive grid structure by this guy
ildefonso da he basically invented the
word for and the study of urbanization
when he laid out this grid plan for
Barcelona that evenly distributed
resources like schools and hospitals but
super block designers insist that cities
don't need a simple grid structure to
implement this kind of plan it can work
anywhere now cities in the US have
attempted some car minimizing projects
like this the problem is they're usually
done in wealthier areas with lots of
existing businesses zoning policies
often require separation of residential
areas and commercial areas but an ideal
walkable area would be a mix of the two
on top of that zoning minimums on
parking availability encourage the
presence of cars and parking lots and
minimums on street with make for really
wide on walkable streets and because of
that walkable districts are basically
isolated luxury items in the u.s. what
makes the Barcelona plan different is
that they are setting aside one fancy
neighborhood or town square to make
pedestrian friendly instead by proposing
super blocks throughout the entire city
they've declared car free spaces are
right for everybody no matter what part
of town they're in maybe this might be
overly optimistic but I think it's sunk
in in the u.s. that the model whereby
every city resident comes with a car and
drives a car everywhere is just
inherently limited it limits the growth
of your city it limits the health of
your city and the growth of your city so
one way or another we have to find ways
of having a lot of people live close to
one another without all of them having
cars you're being able to get around and
work and play and live and have
enjoyable lives without cars
this is all the American rule books
[Music]
you
[Music]